oh my god are we scraping the bottom of
the barrel meet the blacks like that's
one of the two white release movies is
coming out near me this week is meet the
blacks and God's not dead - we are in
for a time folks
mate the blacks so meet the blacks is an
attempt at comedy the Stars Mike Epps
and in a montage at the beginning in
animated form you kind of fills you in
on the events of his life is a girl by
the way I lived in Chicago and I stole
money from this guy who went to jail now
we live in Beverly Hills in a really big
mansion with my family okay so start the
movie and after that it's a messy ass
wreck involving his family as kid
dresses like a vampire's name is Carl's
juniors daughters hooking up with this
guy it's just like eventually don't care
about your like I don't care like the
creepy uncle is like whacking off to his
wife for no reason whatsoever and you
know later on in the movie these guys he
stole money from are gonna come after
him and try to get his money back oh and
by the way the purge is happening in
this movie yeah not making that [ __ ] up
I'm not saying like an offshoot of the
purge I'm saying they call it the purge
it's the purge so among this messy ass
rec we now have a purge spoof that you
can tell wants to take itself seriously
it's like we don't want to be like scary
movie to scream we want to actually be a
legacy comedy we want to be a legacy
spoof like airplane so at best meet the
blacks is purge fan fiction at worst
meet the blacks is exactly what you
think is going to be yeah I don't know
which one you want to go with but those
are your two options here none of the
jokes landed I didn't laugh in the movie
first of all Mike Epps I've never really
found him funny and he is not
charismatic enough to carry a movie be
it a terrible spoof movie yeah he's just
not the guy for that he's the guy when
Kevin Hart has 27 movies coming out here
like alright Mike Epps Kevin Hart's
books you want it that's what happened
I haven't googled it but when you do
you're going to come back be like yes
exactly what happened guys the point is
in a comedy number one thing you need to
laugh and when you don't laugh it's just
all it's a waste of time but the movies
sloppy ass and messy you're not going to
laugh and you're just going to be like
why is all this [ __ ] happen is literally
plot points are being thrown on screen
there is no flow then this purge thing
happens it takes it to the next level of
messy in fact some of my gripes about
this movie funny enough are the gripes I
had about the original purge movie these
guys are breaking into a house but they
have to have a purge to explain the fact
that they can do that but it's a home
invasion movie you don't need a purge to
explain it why there is actually a purge
in this movie
less sense than there being a purge in
the original purge movie the purge too
though that [ __ ] was pretty kick-ass I
had fun time with that one yeah cuz when
people are getting grill owed that's a
pretty good time guys in the end meet
the blacks what is it why is it why did
it happen there's a comedy that's not
funny starring a guy who couldn't carry
the movie in a movie that's a wreck
that's also a bird spoof that you wonder
why on earth it's a bird spoof and I'm
just saying meet the blacks is [ __ ]
purge fan fiction right guys so what is
the worst spoof movie you've ever seen
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more you're right I'm
not even asking if you've watch this
movie because you haven't